hello
hello
people
are we live
hey
i think so
one second
t pose it up
what up stan how are you
a miro
a good morning
um
hi ethan
moonwall me too man me too
uh
pockets
yum
uh
oh okay we're good
uh oh
dude it is so hot here
it's ridiculously uh humid actually
humidity is kind of nuts
i think it's supposed to be a real feel
of like 105 today
what up guys
good morning
welcome
we're gonna jump into it today it's
gonna go
what do we need to do
there's so much
well actually we're we're really getting
down to
the end game guys
we're almost there
i think we've done
every quest line
well we need to go finish millicents so
i think that's what we're gonna start
with today
um
could do that
later because i like to be at level 120
before finding melania i think we can do
it though
so we might just go to the halo tree now
yeah i lived in florida for a little
while i didn't really like it
i'm in the midwest like middle of the
u.s
missouri
we could go to what's easier haley tree
or mogwin palace because we can do
either one
that's what we should do
do i have
no
that's probably what we should do
i think moog's palace is mogwin's palace
is easier than the halo tree
so that would probably be the right
order of things
let's do that
it is rick
we are godric
get mogued
it's mogan time
oh god wait why is it so dark
probably because it's night time dummy
i've never been here when it's this dark
also what is this flickering you see
that weird
nerd
what this
hi metal good morning
how are you
it's mogan time
okay hopefully everything sounds good i
uh messed around with some stuff
we got new overlays that i think look a
lot better
a lot cleaner cool alerts and stuff
we did some work
oh god
okay we're good
who's your favorite demigod radon
i get asked that every day but
definitely radon radon's my favorite in
the game
personally my favorite
let's go uh finish off lieutenant's
quest
we go we we can do that right over here
sounds good
oh cool can you move please
thank you
multiple of them
time to cringe
kind of
cringe no simping when god rick is
watching
something is allowed here
okay you consent for whoever you desire
radon is miyazaki's favorite boss
i can see that i don't know miyazaki
personally
i think radon's
a lot of what's your favorite boss in
the game chat
mine hasn't hasn't wavered from radon
oh this is gonna be
scary
we gotta book it people oh god
[Music]
we're done in moog
let's go finish off with hannah
morgot
morgot is really freaking cool like his
story is awesome
daddy lou
yes sir
yes sir
you love the soundtrack of falling star
beast
i like it i like a lot of music in the
game i think elden rings music is sort
of
i don't know if you guys agree with this
but somewhat like forgettable i don't
know i like the main demigod boss music
though
look at this chick
frickin huge dude
wow okay
okay let's summon
[Music]
young lieutenant towering sister of arse
let the birthing drop lit in
and create me
for us
for all the albanorics
did she just get her preggos
think so thank you
i finally fulfilled my purpose
oh nice
our young yet towering sister will give
us hope
know that nothing is left unfinished
i will join you in battle to the bitter
end
and when the fighting is done
then you may lay me to rest
oh beside lobo
my dear wolf
what if this is mikala
you imagine
kinda
no nichola's a dude
but does gender matter in this game here
here you go chad i see you asking
wow
giant pose
why is she so much bigger than the rest
really cool
yeah i looked up selen's face she's hot
put emote 2.0 exactly exactly
jihad
all right let's knock this thing down
for the funsies
okay
one foot down
once you get below this thing it doesn't
really matter it's shooting all this
stuff
we gotta go we gotta go
that was close what up glenn
she's the original albanork
is that it
they all look the same she's just way
bigger
that's all all of the almond orcs male
and female look the same
all is well glenn
how about you
i want to know more about these
mausoleums there's like a lot i feel
like we're missing
should we get one of these maybe later
we have the option
huge
huge mage ball i mean that's what she is
now
all right we're gonna go to mogwon's
palace
that's our next place
hurt my back golfing and i can't walk
bro you gotta stretch
didn't stretch
oh man
i know where it is i got it
what ending is your favorite
i don't know if i have a favorite ending
i want to say like the coolest one is
frenzy flame
lord of chaos
ending just because it's like it makes
the biggest difference i think besides
ronnie like ronnie's makes a big
difference obviously we just can't see
that big difference it doesn't really
show us it just like shows us the moon
and we're like i bet
oh yeah i can get invaded here
but with the flame of frenzy ending we
get to see like all the flames and
everything going crazy
it's really cool
it's time to get mowed boys wow
i can't even hurt that thing i'm gonna
try
yo what up cup
nice try idiot
okay your try was way better than i
thought
that guy can kill you so fast if you're
not ready
real talk dust guide queen ronnie milner
or someone else i
firmly believe it's melano
or i i believe melano is a
fragment of the glomide queen
and then when we release dust and death
we can see the full glomide queen
which is at the end of the flame of
frenzy ending where we see her with the
glom eye and the dark hair and that's
what i believe
yes metal i got
murdered
it happens
okay
you guys come in here
every day
horny as hell
every day
bruh
bruh
my game's lagging there we go
we just got a big update to the game too
well a lot of bug fixes
that i think people are unhappy with but
is what it is
there's one sub not auto renew i have no
idea bro no clue
i'm pretty sure it auto renews
oh i don't get invaded again okay
never mind that was stupid
[Music]
bang
ew do you hear that thing
gross
yeah melania could be the glow my
queen's daughter
that's a good fake
we don't know i think she's a fragment
of the glow my food that's that's my
that's my guess
because we ain't gonna know for sure
bro this build is hard with this guy
especially get close to the slugs
i'm happy not horny okay
i like that
i am completely stuck in a corner
wow
i love your videos you should have a lot
more subs i think we have a lot of subs
already which is pretty nice
i have no idea what the dlc will be
all i know is it's going to be cool or
really confusing but probably both
happy 28 months
guys it's called memberships here glenn
and metal
i know we streamed on twitch for four
years
but
come on
memberships they're actually called
sponsors
look up the best rune farm no i'm not a
pleb
i'm not a plebeian
oh glenn you upgraded huh
nice bro
thanks for becoming a tarnish dude
you're not a tarnish a great rune
actually thank you man i appreciate you
also can i just no i can't just go into
the hole damn
damn it
hopefully that updates in a second but
thank you glenn
thanks for the i think two months
and becoming a great room appreciate it
wait you subbed on twitch why would you
do that i don't do anything on twitch
anymore you forehead
[Music]
i'm just gonna do that to you
maybe that'll
oh
we gotta heal
you don't got nothing
what is that
i jumped over it
there we go guys first try right
no you can't go through the portal
unless you beat him
so there we go
oh you got little magic spells
interesting
i told you
already it's because i use the emotes
all right
fine
fair enough
imagine i dlc for every ending
that
would be confusing
but cool
what's your favorite souls game
hmm
[Music]
i would say eldon ring
i think eldon ring
well
i guess i have an opinion for what's the
best souls game and what's my personal
favorite
i think my personal favorite souls game
is either bloodborne or dark souls 3
but i think eldon ring
is their best game
are you begging me to rune farm are you
are you okay in the brain
ew
dark souls 2.
uh
it's it's some people's favorite it's
not mine
but it can be yours
i don't know man it sounded like you
were begging me to ruin farm it's kind
of weird
but yeah that was the famous
pickpock rune farming position
yeah irithyll knights are tough they're
tough man
yep metal babe hates
hates
dark souls 2.
dude the saw is so sick i'm glad i
brought it back from bloodborne is there
a saw in this game
it's pretty
can those cool skeletons be killed i
don't think they can be killed they can
be it's like uh you can kill the
summoner
and then they won't
mess with you know
well here are the smithing stone
sevenths
our weapons fully upgraded so we're good
rick is about to fight
moog i don't know about you guys but i
struggle against moog so this might take
some uh
oh the pizza cutter is what you're
talking about yeah of course
uh yeah this might take a few attempts
it's gonna be tough
i love
that there's a merchant back here
nerd
oh yeah do i need that uh crystal tear
remote
i usually just heal through it but i
could use that
yeah
[Music]
this guy doesn't have a donkey and i
feel bad for him
[Music]
hold on my [ __ ] ain't updating
reload
[Music]
hmm
okay hopefully that'll kick into gear
for you glenn i don't know what's going
on with that but
probably have to re-log into that
i don't know if that'll end the stream
i'll give it a bit
hate is always the answer
i think i hate anything
do you guys really hate stuff
i don't think i hate anybody or anything
is that jermaine's theme
hey what anything
i fully believe the only people that
love dark souls 2 are people who played
the get that game first
maybe yeah
you hate the bet of chaos
i don't think it's a good boss but i
don't hate it
i hate my girlfriend okay now we're
now we're getting political
i agree with that muppets
hating things takes a lot of effort
and i just don't
want to do that
you mean to tell me that you don't hate
movie theaters popcorn popcorn's effect
on you
did i tell the chat what what popcorn
movie particularly movie theater popcorn
does to my body
anyone want to take a guess
actually you probably already know but
let me know if this happens to you and
it's only movie theater popcorn
movie theater popcorn gives me severe
diarrhea every single time
i'll take i'll take five
five bites and it's like yup
just diarrhea
[Music]
the weapon i'm using is fully upgraded
silly so i don't need it right now
but i love pop like i could uh
microwave a bag of popcorn
and it won't give me diarrhea it's
specifically
movie theater popcorn
i'm literally in the restroom right now
and i ate movie theater popcorn
yesterday see
mine's immediate though
i don't hate that though
i feel lighter after i have diarrhea
that's a positive outlook on that i
suppose
right
at any movie theater does the same thing
oh i didn't get the thing that you guys
wanted me to get oh well i'll just heal
through the
me he'll
[Applause]
as a bunch of coconut oil
i'm allergic
to nuts
so
maybe coconuts have that effect on me
you're so out of pocket right now dude i
don't give a [ __ ]
i don't give up
you guys think moog was inside of his
blood
like that's why it dripped out of his
arm is he like trying to
get him to wake up inside of him or
something
[Applause]
dearest
we'll say his voice
was not what i expected it to be
you must abide alone a while
he sounds so nice here and then he just
turns it
honor to guest
to the birthplace
of our dentist
dynasty
is he just saying dynasty wrong
rp walk
dress
ah what's happening
what the audio why does it do that
randomly
so weird
[Music]
how's my game
oh come on
ow
that's a reach smoke
when you make mokes stagger
[Music]
i'm really glad i asked that question in
that exact moment that was kind of
awesome
let's get it boys
and girls
get him buddy
he gets so fast stage two yep there it
is he's mine and by the way holy [ __ ]
yeah mimic rick is kind of bad
those were some really bad dodges there
on my end
you died
that's one of our emotes by the way if
you guys decide to become a member
just so you know just so you're aware of
that
get out of here now that comes straight
down pretty much
that's not good
see that attacks fast bro
why not get a better weapon
what's wrong with this weapon it's
really good
oh that's pain
that just increases bleed okay
[Music]
that's a swing as well
oh no i didn't know that until now
i don't know why i did that
bad decision
i thought i could roll
oh
bro dude
we're fine
this is fine
fight's so cool
[Music]
hey
wow
[Music]
the [ __ ]
delayed swing man
bonkers
[Music]
almost died
[Music]
all right no healing
i don't know how that hits
what
i saw my character roll and i still got
hit okay
dude stage two is nuts
i find stage one to be pretty easy and
then stage two is like well
no i don't have the item
i'm just gonna do it without the item
hey whatever
see how the mimic does at the start
i don't have the shackle
actually i think i do i'm just i don't
know
i don't think it does enough to like use
it
like it's okay
get some free heads
these confused bro
that's what we like to see right there
there it is
keep hitting
keep going
he's going for him too ah interesting
[Music]
those wings are so [ __ ] awesome
what oh no
bad swing
no way come on
i'm gonna run into fire
oh we should probably fight melancholic
before this huh i don't think we've done
that
kind of early mode
dude i i struggle so hard with these
attacks in stage two they're so weird
health debuff
oh i do
must be from fia
that forehead
there we go
we need to level up in the farming spot
i just don't believe in that i don't
believe in ruined farming i think that's
you can do whatever you want i just
don't want to do that
i will get it eventually i just need to
learn the move set in stage two again
hard
to get these
we gotta help our boy out
getting on right now
nice
take it take it
there was an update for elden ring today
yep
nice roll jake nice roll
hold on
that's unfortunate
what is that spray
nice
no other rip
okay
this is good
where is he going what
is mine
where was he going
he just like
morphed
mid-air
that was going so well
pain
okay i'm gonna say this now
stop backseating chat let me do it my
way
don't stop it you're not
helping
maybe a little bit
did i not use the correct oh i need to
use this i think
yeah i pretty much got one shot at there
i need to change the difficulty to
recruit
yes
that'll definitely help
[Music]
oh i hate that oh that's actually an
attack
that was cool
[Music]
dick
i thought i was under his armpits
these nuts
other rick
very nice
i was like can he go that far of course
he can
that's unfortunate
that [ __ ] delay dude and then the
blood loss beautiful
and then i stand in some more [ __ ]
it's just around
come on jake
that was beautiful
there's still fire over here okay
okay that has some range to it
dang it where are you going
we're getting closer
you got this mogan time
um
dang it
i can't believe we're fighting moog
before malacath
that's a good try though
i just like this fight
it's a good fight
it's time to mode this moog
no i thought i was behind him
do it
get him
keep hitting
okay
stay alive mother rick
nice
oh this is the one this is the one
come on guys
didn't count
growing
actually almost
dang it other rick
[Music]
uh
i can't believe that hit me bro
dude it goes so well and then it just
goes so not well so fast
it's hard
gonna get it
i'm gonna wait to use other rick
nice opening idiot
okay i can't get that one
as i still try to do that
[Music]
he's got some [ __ ] range on that
fire bro
[Music]
french
yep
fair enough
i learned
learning
don't swing
try to bait me [ __ ]
don't swing
that's exactly what we wanted
didn't help our what we wanted
that might have been perfect
it did
no wrong button
go go go
come on other rick
yes other rick
dammit
no
oh the pain
he chucks it
that hit
i should have healed
dude right when his health is this low
he just goes so crazy dude
not other rick
i think that's the way though we summon
him a little bit later
like near stage two and then we're okay
i got a little greedy there i really did
oh come on bro come on cheek
[Music]
let's roll right into that
that attack is sus
i [ __ ] roll dude
i thought he might stagger there just a
maybe
oh
you know how we talked about how i hate
don't hate anything there you go i
already lost my ruins poop
[Music]
yeah mo chill out
i don't even want nicola
that attack it really is us
rip ruins
it's not like we won't get a bunch for
this
you know
look at that i'm gonna do this
that does so much more damage than the
stab
nice
that [ __ ] run on my body
you're swinging right after that all
right fair enough
[Music]
that missed alrighty then
going forward again
[Music]
nice
won't matter
avoid some damage get out of here
[Music]
range
[Music]
oh my god it already broke i'm upset
about that
how do i attack him right now look at
this
there's a spire if
i don't know how i'm alive i don't know
what health i had but it wasn't a lot
we gotta just go
oh my god that couldn't have gone worse
he just has all this fire everywhere
it's so hard to attack him
all right
time to do what every good player will
tell me
get good [ __ ]
right chat
[Music]
the fact that he can just chuck
blood at you and it hurts you as soon as
it hits you
god damn
we're getting close though that just the
the second phase just went as bad as it
could have
nicholas mine and mine alone
[Music]
guys does the shackle even do that much
because whenever i used it it didn't do
[ __ ]
like it hit him down for like 10 like
five seconds it didn't even matter
everyone talks about the shack
right
you [ __ ]
he does that pretty much every time i
need to i need to just memorize that
good call jake good call maybe one here
little roll yep nice
we're getting good we're getting better
this is great
not the time to attack there
second throw don't attack
he was baiting me
freaking hoe
okay okay
let's get this off
any other attack
would have been fine
literally any other attack when we were
good there
okay
get in there boys
rolled way too early that was bad
it was my fault
time to just get good
horrible rolls as i say that
very nice rick let's go
try using shackles
jesus
there yeah
yep die rick not yet
okay
i jumped over him oh my god
let's go
we got good boys we got good
hey jake you should you should use the
shackle oh you could you could use a
better weapon as well
imagine playing soldier of god rick
you could you're not going to be able to
beat moog like that bro you should use
the shackle dude
should i use the shackle dude
[Music]
dude why is your build so bad
gonna use the shackle true
true
that's just facts
i like that
hey chat
hey chat
get up
weird okay yeah shackle these nuts
all right i'm over it i'm over it yeah
mickeleh looks really weird in the
cocoon he looks uh
i'm not fully convinced this is mikola
i think moog's insane
but it could be
no
all right
all right
well not getting up there now
moog you
lmao you died like a million times prior
how many times did i die like five
with no crack tear
up chat
well i'm gonna try something real quick
i don't even know if this is gonna end
the stream or not i really hope not but
hold on
old
we will be back if the stream ends i
have to do something
at least i think hold on
that is on
yep
um
old
you see that that just ain't doing it
all right hold up hold
keep holding
keep talking so i know you guys are
still here keep talking so i know you're
here
because i'm scared right now i'm scared
i think you guys are
uh
yep we're gonna do that
successful
keep pause champion
excellent we're still here okay that's
good to know
glenn for for whatever reason your
membership just didn't just does not go
through the alerts
which is cringe
all right we're good thank you for pause
champion i appreciate it thank you for
the help chat you're all amazing
except for the people
that were [ __ ] talking me during that
fight your cringe
okay
let's go see if we can upgrade our mimic
because he's kinda
youtube said [ __ ] you glenn pretty much
you're here for some spirit tuning why
are you so sad rodrigo
like if you think stuff is cringe then
you're cringe it's great
to craft a weapon which could slay a god
though i can't help but think of it as a
curse
a fearsome curse you guys think you
could beat moog in an irl fight like
real life
moog in front of you you think you can
box them
do you like fia i mean she's i
jacob you called everything cringe
yesterday
that's my point
exactly
all right i don't have a four so
whatever i don't care let's go beat up
uh all right you guys want dragon lord
or malacath next
oh i haven't even gone to
a tangy yet
temple lift rooftop that's what we want
we already beat moog
we're the best
oh let's go get our runes because we
have both of them now and i thought
way earlier it would have been fun to
see both of them in the same spot
fringe lord your mom is cringe how about
that buddy
and i would know
you should try to fight moog next
i
dragon lord because you need dragon
balls
to summon elden beast
bear bear
bear
through
oh or melania what do you guys like what
do you want what do you guys want to do
i think we're strong enough to beat
melania if we can beat moog
and this weapon will stun the [ __ ] out
of her
all right let's see both rooney boys up
here
i don't think i've never seen this
before i know they're in the same tower
but i've never seen them next to each
other that is epic
i'd like that look at that twin twin
great runes right next to each other
[Music]
pretty cool
[Music]
[Music]
all right what great room we using
what should we uh what should we do
right now i'm wearing godric's
this was right here the whole time all
right
not upgrading flash bro i should do that
huh holy [ __ ]
oh i don't have any
and we're fine
mogurs
stick with godric's
moogs
morgot
let's see
so we have raises all attributes just
damn good
damn good
restores hp upon defeating enemies
that's horrible
don't like it what up rattlesnake
radons raises maximum hp fp and stamina
i think that's really good for our build
actually
like very good
raise greatly raises maximum hp and
you know it is what it is there and then
grants a
blessing of blood to phantoms
which is kind of weird we definitely
don't want to use moogs that's that's
bad
i'm gonna can we do a poll let's do a
poll i'm gonna take
i guess i can do all of them can i
no i can only do four
uh
okay
so
godric we're not going to use smoke
godric
radon
more got
right card i guess
community
it's 15 for radon that's pretty good
it's not bad
it'll complete the build
i'm leaving it up the chat chat gets to
choose
so make sure you vote this is a
democracy here until i decide it's not
and then make the decision for you
this is this is my domain my stream
it's a democracy until i choose that it
isn't
essentially
okay radon's winning so far
i'm not voting i want moak
mogu is completely useless to us for the
most part
democracy is cringe
i
i'm alyssa
it looks like radon's gonna gonna pull
out the dub here
yeah it's winning by like
a lot
mogots
godric will make this build great again
i've been using godric this entire time
i haven't i actually haven't had a great
rune on so
or a uh
ruin arc on so it hasn't even been a
factor
radon seems better in late game i agree
let's go with radon you guys seem to
want radon we're gonna go with radon
bet
that voice
redone
good job ladies and gentlemen
the next order of business i'm just
going to go based on chat here just
based on what you guys said
per se in the chat are we going
to melania
dragonlord or malacath
what do you guys want
right cards is okay
no idea red dawn
two dragon lords malketh
dragonlord melania melania dragonlord
melania it's catching up to melania now
pretty much between
dragon lord and melania let's let's go
beat the dragon lord first i i think
that makes more sense let's let's go do
that
all right
let's get it
cringe lord place a deuce axe
[Music]
okay
the true boss of elden ring
birds
blind birds apparently
[ __ ]
[Music]
anyone else just sprint through this
area every time
use a rune to activate it well
if i had one
i would
so let me get to where i'm getting bro
you impatient [ __ ]
keyword
wannabe
that's what you are bruh
uh oh
almost died
wannabe
a wannabe
if anything millennial should buff
flasks we deserve o.p roon after such a
difficult boss
you guys think melania is hard
here's a better question because you're
all going to say yes
or some of you will say no and you're
just weird but
do you think melania is fair
i think that's a better question
do you think melania is fair
i say yes
my boy backed up
moog is a trillion times harder one more
billion times harder
waterfowl dance is hard not melania
that's a good way to put it
i don't like waiting for her thousand
attack chain combos to end
i agree i don't like it either i don't
like that attack the rest of the fight i
think is awesome
let's go get some rune arcs
cause i just want to get up here
[Music]
of course she's fair she says our name
nah fire giant's easy
when you figure him out i think everyone
struggled with the fire giant at first
because i didn't know how to fight him
i know i did
i struggled heavy heavy
with uh
with the fire giant
now now i can pretty much one shot him
every time
still in here bro
what are you doing in here
you burned the oak tree didn't you yeah
i did the round table is soon to follow
no need to fret about that
the round table holds serve to put a
tarnish upon the throne of elden lord
and if the earth tree needed to burn for
that to happen then the rounds probably
depends on the build too
mogwin's palace about the lord of
blood's cocoon
ah
i see
so michela was with the lord of blood
after all
that is some fine intelligence indeed
yeah it is with it
the final clue has been brought into the
light
one of the last few pieces the round
table
i need
to put everything together
as promised weird allow me to impart to
you
the lust of the secret rights
known only to me
law of car casual
law of casuals
okay
well i wonder what comes next
if he continues his slumber within the
cocoon all would be well
but perhaps it would be safer to destroy
it
nicholas the one thing that remains a
mystery to me
interesting
oh so that's where the so-called lord of
blood was hiding himself eh
a fitting little squad for that deluded
maniac to bleat about the revival of his
precious dynasty
while he turns out i think it took me
several hours to beat the fire giant let
him stay there
that way this my build wasn't good for
it
i think i was there way
unattainable
but
perhaps it's worth looking into
if what i've heard is right then
maybe
ah
my apologies
lost myself for a moment there the
information you've shared is of great
value
as promised
your reward
and it is a wondrous thing indeed
you are a true fellow
all i asked is that you remain constant
bevers cookbook
i'm curious um what is that incantation
what does it say
of casuality
one of the key fundamentals manifests a
small ring of casuality within that
follows the caster to automatically
retaliate oh that's what he uses against
us
the fundamentalists describe the golden
order through the powers of regression
and causality legality is
casuality is the pull between meanings
that which links all things in a chain
of relation
it's really interesting
what does he mean by the queen's despair
uh probably mikala being
taken
that's my
guess
okay we got our runarcs let's go fight
placidus
place to do sacks
first playthrough bleed
made melania trivial
skipped her in my second run but the
third i took the stagger down power
stance more got swords nice
wait we gotta go down
like melania's despair
you talking about
america right
like nicola being taken
they don't know where he is so
i'm sure she didn't like that
placid dick sacks huh
do you think mickela will be harder than
melania
no i don't know
we don't even we don't know anything
about mikola to be honest we can ramble
about what we think we know about
mickela but
there's really not much
he's he seems to be
really [ __ ] powerful
but we just don't know
yep he's gonna be goku
yep he was sucking on mogu was sucking
on his toes that's all we know
age is harder than melania
just think of the difference between
germain or orphan or nameless king and
gayle
i find nameless king to be way harder
than gail
that's just me though everyone's
different
nicholas a kid
no well he's not necessarily a kid he
just has eternal youth
so like he looks like a kid and will
always be a kid but he's been around for
who knows how long
orphan of course
is really hard
that's all i'll say about that
ridiculously hard
yeah see it it depends on your build it
depends on you know like what kind of
move sets you guys like fighting against
like that's what really dictates
difficulty this depends
it's like victor struggled with fire
giant just like i did and some people
beat him first try
i just don't think it matters
i don't think anything's actually dead
it doesn't seem like anybody actually
dies when we kill them
created unalloyed gold then fashioned
the halogen tree which could have grown
to be much more powerful than the urgery
exactly so like he's a he's stuck in
eternal youth but i don't think he's uh
he's very strong
very knowledgeable as well i think
all right let's get it boys
and
girls let's go
yo what up cub
getting that armpit
ah that reaches huh i i bet bit but
[Music]
haha your tails tiny
[Music]
got your leg
[Music]
little stagger
can i reach him
god i feel like that does no damage
run
this is the coolest attack in the game
that's so cool
[Music]
[Music]
fire fire fire fire fire
[Applause]
i can't i can't
[Music]
your vacuum exploded
he go
i'm halfway down almost doing okay
no i didn't want to lose that
dang it
i do need more sacred tears
[Music]
sometimes i can dodge that and sometimes
i can
oh i got a hit
what
oh bro that hurt
[Music]
yeah i hate this attack
[Music]
that attack scares me
[Music]
we're gonna take the hit there
we'll take a couple hits here actually
we'll be fine
uh
this is fine
we're gonna we're just gonna hit we're
gonna [ __ ] hit i can't get out of
here
unfortunately
see i rolled into him there and it still
hits you i don't
sometimes the lightning just goes in a
different direction
i killed him when he was teleporting
he just pops back in nice
let's go
first try actual first try there
very nice
very very nice
this build is actually not bad
i agree pro gamer
yeah we need to kill melania get the
golden needle
uh do millicent's quest line that's
pretty we're almost done guys
did i just stream for a long time today
and just get it done
what weapon does his remembrance give
um
we go find out
we gotta kill melania to cure the
frenzied flame
let's go find out
you've done it i see yeah i did what use
do you have for me now i don't i'm a
finger reader
i will remain here until their dialogue
ends and the thinkers speak again
do as you please
take please whatever course seems most
worthy to you
now you may go
she's like eh do whatever you want
you could force this tired old crone to
work
even
we're getting close to so i'm gonna let
chat pick um what ending we want so
we're gonna have to decide after we beat
melania we're gonna have to decide what
ending we want
so because um
well i guess we could wait couldn't we
yeah we could always wait to cure the
frenzied flame and then have all the
endings at the end
so yeah
that's fine so you get ortusack's
lightning spear
oh that's for the sax excuse me
dragon king's crag blade
here's some gravel stone sword
containing primeval
yeah primeval lighting a portion of the
dragon lord's power gained from a
remembrance this weapon commands great
power over the paltry mortal dragons of
today
wow
neat
and then you get the dragon breath
where he does the lasers it's pretty
cool
but i think um i think we're gonna wait
yeah we just if we want to do claim a
frenzy ending then we'll uh we can just
go to the end
um yeah we can wait till we get to the
end actually to to vote i'm on pc
might as well stream it's raining at
work yeah i don't plan on going outside
today because it's ridiculously humid
and hot out
so i might stay in and [ __ ] stream
all day dude
because i want to i want to get this
done
i really do
yeah i might as well stream because it's
raining at your work got it
yeah i want the nuke ability that was
cool
all endings
well we have the option for all indians
okay
melania or malacath you guys choose
you're gonna pick melania aren't you i'm
just gonna go ahead and go there
because that's exactly what you're gonna
pick
what happens next after we finish elden
ring
we'll have to see
i should
use these huh
oh my god i have so many runes holy
shite
let me go back and
sell all this
melania melania malcath actually it
seems pretty split all of you are saying
malacath actually
laney is too hard now
115 is definitely doable for her
we play it again with a different build
i was thinking we could go back and play
bloodborne
that would be cool
about the god slain weapon what happened
to her
i upset the girl yeah i said 120 but 115
is doable
i'm free
but if i stay here i will be ruined with
the round table
will you survive for freedom now
i smith weapons to slay a god
i have lived and will die doing so upon
this spot
is there any other way
i think we're about to get the 120 right
now
about the god slain weapon yes i'm
my masterpiece to slay a god
that's all i've lived for
yes won a golf stream
i'm a promised queen america
would do me a favor i have been golfing
a lot lately
don't look after the girl
okay
yeah let's sell
how many rooms do we have 599 000
whoa
albatross run yeah that's never gonna
happen
all right
so dex we can get our hit up pretty high
650
654
what if i how many levels are we doing
here six so let's do one two three
two three 152
154 seems like dex is our way to go
let's do it
that's 121.
soldier
of god rick is looking amazing
when girls want to hear when girls want
to hear i love you but the guys are just
interested in talking about the god
slayer
exactly
i see i'm gonna pull it because it
seemed like that was really close
oh she don't talk anymore wrench all
right i'm gonna pull it i'll do whatever
you guys want
melania
uh mal a cat
ask your community
god
rick
the all-knowing
i'm on pc
oh 50 50 split off the bat oh [ __ ]
that's why i wanted to do the poll it
was super close
ah no
e3
oh it came back a little bit
well i'm gonna go get a crafting kit
because i want to use something against
melania so keep voting keep voting boys
i haven't had a crafting kit this entire
damn time
thank you chrysilla mick mick rozilla
thank you
good morning
wait
no no no
oh i do have a crafting kit nevermind
we're good
goodbye bye
55-45
millennia
crafting isn't useless
let's see so
i want to use pots
against her when she does the waterfowl
that seems to help
a lot
so i think a fire pot would do fine
right
rancher pot
and make three
does a fire pot work on her i think it
does
i'm gonna give it a shot
so we have three of those
we've got a long journey to even get
there
so
let's just get going because it's going
to be a while before we even get to
millennia to be honest i have a little
uh secret way to get to her faster
uh we also need to do millicent's quest
line so we're going to do that as well
fire pots don't
why why wouldn't that work
i'm gonna go ahead and say it does or
we're gonna test it if it doesn't then
we can make other [ __ ]
where does that go
why is this kind of scary
i understand now
[ __ ] birds dude
so
let me stick it
nice
what's this thing doing over here
wrench
oh
got it oh okay okay yeah these birds
suck dude i will i will say that
definitively that the death right birds
are the worst bosses in this game they
are [ __ ] terrible
to fight against i hate fighting them
oh
i'm reading freeze pots can actually
stop yeah i know freeze pots worked
but i didn't know if uh
fire pots did
we're gonna try them
the worst
enemies in the game are these birds
i i like the gargoyles i think they're
fine
okay it's not nighttime
oh well
we'll come back
that is true macadamia that is true
i think the gargoyles are are easy death
rights eat it
what are you doing
being a little spirit okay
oh god the worst area in the [ __ ]
game bro
we're getting into bad territory to be
honest
this town
is awful anybody else agree
this town is
awful
i killed moog so i have no idea what
you're talking about overhead
whoops
every archer is chris kyle on stimulants
facts
hey look at this though
look at that just skipped an entire
archer
now you know
i'm scared to go up there
see that maneuvering [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
they deserve it
first tried right through there baby
that was some pro level dodging
you guys think this is mickela by the
way i think it is
statue
nicholas kind of cute
no cap
okay
now
we're gonna go down
i'm gonna get shot in the back right now
you don't
you suck
all right another one
boom
easy skip
it's saint trina but isn't it theorized
that mikala is saint trina
yeah it does look like the same child
embracing melania
agreed
if i can get through this town in one
try i'm
i think i'm a legend if i do that i
think i'm i'm i i think i'm the best if
i can get that done
you you would all have to definitively
call me the best elden ring player in
the world
i think that's fair
somebody's gonna [ __ ] grab me here in
a second
i hear you
[ __ ] off
yep i'm better than whoever that is
yup
you tried to get me
but you suck
[Music]
i think that's it
let's go
easy clap first try hardest boss in the
game is just that town
i couldn't have done it if i wasn't rick
let's go
i'm the best player ever it it is a
known fact now because i just did that
now time to die 400 times in here
[Music]
oh no did i forget our catchphrase
already i think i did
shut up
i hate horns
oh rick is roll
these guys are getting rick rolled right
now
bye
have a great time
oh it didn't fall
i wanted him to fall
it would have been funny
oh god
big boy inbound
now you smell you're bad bye
guarantee that guy smells
man doesn't use soap in the shower
imagine
[Music]
couldn't be me
i don't [ __ ] around with bugs i don't
like bugs in real life and i don't like
them in this game we move around the
bugs
we can't give our horse an apple so the
game sucks
i think they under utilize torrent
like big time in this game i don't know
why though
it's torrance poggers
but i feel like he was underutilized
lost me as a sub didn't realize you were
so egotistical
nice
if you thought i was serious there then
i don't want you to be a sub
is your forehead all right do i have any
poppy boys
your
ear
[Music]
can't even see the testes shrink in the
snow so you guys are talking about red
dead huh
get that 50 just because that's a nice
number
good [ __ ] boys good [ __ ] and girls can
the girls be a part of the boys are we
not cool with that
bubble blowing
a baby
cash money
all right
that was insane
girls can be a part of the boys i bet
i bet
we got here
that's big that's big
okay that hurt my feelings
we identify as i would think of it as
you guys are a part of the boys
ah only one
bruh
[Music]
stop
attacking me
your cringe
here we go
there we go
no i love red dead too it's definitely
my top ten games of all time
can we play that on stream that could be
[ __ ] hilarious
his role play is rick again
in red dead too
play that on stream have a pretty good
time
oh you guys are friends
now i'm cringe because i said fringe
they have to prove themselves
now
women do not need to prove themselves
any more than they already have
honestly i see women as like literal
gods
because they can produce babies i think
that's
probably the coolest thing i've ever
seen
all these guys are big
and then they like redo their body once
a month kind of [ __ ] nuts
yeah i'm not being a sim i'm just
stating [ __ ] facts
if i were a simp i'd be like i really
like this girl's toes that's a sim
i'm just saying girls who can't like
they have like with their periods they
have to like reform their insides
and then they can grow a human being in
their body
is kind of [ __ ] nuts
that's some demonic hell spawn [ __ ]
periods i mean yeah but it's
cool
here's another thing none of you would
exist if it weren't for women just
saying
none of you
does this take me back up yeah
we're talking about women metal
i think of them as literal gods of
humanity
whereas all i have to do is be a guy
i don't have to do any of that [ __ ]
[Music]
no one would exist if it weren't for men
either
yeah
men can't grow you inside of their
bodies though
you know
why haven't you kissed my feet then
because i'm not a simple
ah
re-skin the boss fight
what i roll whoa
oh
pain
might have got a stagger if i got that
one
it's hitting a bit harder here
what
and heck great heavens
wow that is insane damage
did they buff you with loretta
oh
that was almost really bad
almost died there
i've quite literally never seen that
attack
but that was cool
my name
is so aggressive phase two true
he kinda has to be
i shouldn't have brought up the women
thing huh
[Music]
jesus christ
can we all agree that women are cool
and men are cool too
but some women suck and some men suck as
well
can we all agree upon that
no you shouldn't all right
never mind
uh should i do endurance
uh based
men are cool is a tall order
i am soldier godric i'm the best
we need to stop this
[Music]
this shouldn't even be a hot topic
not yet
be playing in 4k
i think the stream's in 4k
because i'm a great streamer right guys
and i have a high quality stream that
you all enjoy and will come back to
every day right
right
professional streamer
this area is really cool
well
don't toy with me hey can we all agree
at least i talked to you guys
i see streamers with 20 000 viewers and
they don't even [ __ ] look at their
chat and it bothers me
at least i'm here for you
damn get home
well well well
if it isn't
again we meet
we can only surmise our purposes are
aligned
in which case did i leave you one ready
to explain myself
i am of melania's blood oh [ __ ] i did in
what capacity i know not
i could be sister
daughter
or an offshoot
whatever the case though
i can't look at a tick tock right now
there is something i must return to
melania the will that was once her own
the dignity
the sense of self it's kind of hard to
like a streamer that doesn't interact i
love how you interact with your audience
i don't sub the people who don't give
thanks where things are due
well that's the thing like none of
content creators wouldn't have anything
if they didn't have an audience so like
why wouldn't you thank them over and
over and over again something nuts
that was once
or interact with them
did i say you promoted yourself i'm
confused now i said i left you on i
can't read a tick tock or watch it
[Music]
there is something i must return to
millenia
the will that was once her own the
dignity
a sense of self
that allowed her to resist the call of
the scarlet rot
ah okay i think that's everything we can
say to her
some weirdo in chats on something oh cat
quit being weird okay thanks
is that going to stop weirdos though no
not at all
oh
damn
someone get through the joke before you
ow
when you pause the stream i have to go
blow up the death star i will come back
shortly sure
imagine
yeah
are you jealous that metal bait 5 has
actually touched my toes irl
this wildhander
whoa
whoa
my name's not aj
what the frick dude
do the melania shortcut should i do it
we gotta do millicent [ __ ] as well
all right you guys ready
for the shortcut
i think it's right here
we about to find out
[Music]
and body hits the button
no your body doesn't get there anymore
no
did they fix it
they fixed the glitch i think i did that
perfectly
what a pascal
how are you
you died i did
i'm not a tow guy
you aren't yet
you saw my toes though chat
you would be
yeah i think this was patched it looks
like
i mean that didn't work at all your body
didn't even get close
i just missed i'm i nailed it i hit it
right on the money
it was a little far
try one more time
that couldn't be more on the button yeah
they patched it
another streamer did it the day before i
know but there was an update literally
today
oh
that would have been bad
i get back up there
yeah there's definitely a kill box there
that was not there before
so i'm gonna go ahead and say that's
patched
i want my runes though
now
the hottest boss is the fire giant
because it's on
fire oh oh
you know what
let's just reset where i am
whoops
guys is the hottest
boss in the game the fire giant because
it's hot because fire
did i just do that again
oh i could have just gone right here
that works
yeah i think that's patched
we're gonna move on
did he double that up
that
fall off
fall off the map oh
just did that attack twice
yeah why are you guys saying me
soldier of rick
soldier of god rick
is clearly the hottest guy in the game
early
i'm the best
except they did that again didn't i
he's too fat
yeah
yeah
where are my runes i don't know
come on
please just let me move for the love of
for the love
for the love
that's all i need is love
hello
really
excellent
well damage being done here is still
nothing
correct jazz
can you please stream again
and i'm gonna keep streaming
everyone shut up
that's op
did not realize how
interesting you all are
great
who is grunting
just going
oh there you are
sir
when's your next stream probably
tomorrow i'm gonna stream every day
until we beat this completionist run
today's day 10 and it would be uh
slightly like nice
okay then
like i was saying
it would be nice
to have 10 episodes
because that's a nice even number right
guys
rolled
your mum
get shot
okay
you know mistakes happen it is what it
is
i joined at a great time you really did
you really did didn't you
let's not get shot this time
it was kind of cringe right guys let's
just not do that again
oh god not these
yo what up
[Music]
oh
what they hurt him too
[Music]
of course not
we
is my chat weird because of me
whoa
this lighting in here is really cool
that's beautiful
yes
i think you're right
there's more of them in here than i
originally thought i'm going to leave
now
a [ __ ] bye
i'm weird for myself nobody else oh hey
probably uh get off of those
so you know
of what's happening to you right now
i'm weird because i'm weird it's all
about my own effort
understandable
hey look tree soldier ashes why did you
come over here now
i now uh
hey look tree night helm
like you can't jump over here can you no
no shot no shot
who's that
now
yes
i've never
gotten to this area the way i just did
that was
interesting way to get here
i think if smokey the bear played elven
ring the frenzied flame ending would
trigger him
that's such an interesting
thought
i hope you you should dive deep into
that deep into that theory
nice to meet you
yes
my name's rick
i'm pickle rick
hey this is where we want to be so
milisense thing should be over there
right
yeah
so
we want to get there's a yeah yeah i
know where to go
i got this
i think this is our last quest line
yeah yeah the bronze the prawns
oh i am moving through here
much slower than i used to
nice nice very good
oh they're little baby fronts
beautiful
ow that was mean
i go down now
gotta find out
there we go
we really are murdering
refugees we actually are hey they attack
us i
they attack us
america's tits you must be hungry
there we go
yeah i know i went past millicent
because i wanted to get that right there
you back cedars
shut up
you missed the thingy
i
know
relax
my guy
oh god we have to kill this thing first
this is gonna suck
oh this thing's so hard to fight we have
to kill this thing first
cool
i thought i could dive through
can't lock on
still can't lock on all right cool i
love that for me
not a time to heal at all and that's
cringe
[Music]
i hate this fight i hate it bro it's so
annoying okay
we gotta do it though
let's put a tree spirit uh
in scarlet rot lol that's exactly the
conversation that went on at from
software
they're like you guys know the tree
spirits and they're like yeah let's put
that in scarlet rot and they can only
fight it there
oh i like that
yeah this has a ton of health try and
stay out
of this
what
this thing never attacks like that hell
all right now it's just consistently
attacking like that all right yep
this is going well
all right
this is going really good
nice head
it rode me
it it wouldn't let me cool
just don't knock me off all right sick
[Music]
just didn't want to get knocked off that
was my main goal don't get knocked off
and
i did
i called it
well
yeah
yep
listen this is just another one of those
moments guys
you just get good you just you just get
better
are you cosplaying a soldier of godric
maybe
all right this isn't what we wanted
oh good
[ __ ] it
i can't even tell where i am right now
so
i'm stuck in its armpit so i just
[Music]
three times
i was stuck in its armpit
at least we are uh near melania that is
that is true we have to do this for
millicent however
i forgot about this [ __ ] guy
this worm dude is so annoying
i think i got it halfway right
should i just tank the scarlet rod
nice
i knock you off the edge
excellent
excellent
there's no [ __ ] way that reached me
[Music]
hey
dude
like
wow
i i got morbed
i guess i got morbed
ah
yeah i bet if you were a magic user you
could stand up here and just spam your
spells at it without it hitting you but
i have a giant ass sword so i can't
[ __ ] touch it
from up there
god i thought it was done
that that missed
okay
just be nice
come on now
it's not nice
not be nice
i'll be nice
okay take the hit on that i guess
it's fine
okay half
not what i wanted
stay here
no that fire [ __ ] hit me
can't even tell what's going on
oh i'm dead
wow that was close
cool i love getting head
are you [ __ ] kidding me
[Music]
sakiro is not dark souls
it's made by the same company
we gotta do our quest line it's a part
of what we're doing
a shorter one behind him
all right
doesn't look safe at all
and i fell all right
what is my guy swinging at bro
i don't even know what the heck it was
doing
please don't knock me off
please
holy [ __ ]
dude i can't even see i
it's not where i want to be
nope
thank
you what
oh
holy [ __ ]
i'm going over here
it explodes after the fact
sit me down right here oh my god
what a cheap shot at the end man
it's like i killed it when it was doing
that load up and the effect still happen
i yeah i think those bosses right there
are horrible designs they're so [ __ ]
bad
those in the death death right birds
bad design
not
visually
but mechanically really bad
alright guys are we helping
or fighting against millicent
kill her or help her
i'll do a poll
ask
we're helping duh alright we'll see
did the scream crash
no
help her she gives you something
yep okay i guess uh we don't need a poll
yep that that's just yep okay got it you
guys are all uh got it all right we will
help
who assist milson
did the stream crash streamer
oh that hurt
i don't want to fall off again please
okay one down one down one down
what i wanted to do
i'm gonna spam this on you for fun
fall off the map yup get [ __ ] own
oh and melissa gets the last one let's
go that was easy peasy
that was
perfect timing
oh yeah we can't get the needle without
helping her can we
all right
let's go talk to her
oh
hello
hi thank you for lending your hand
you're welcome without your help
i could not have defeated that quartet
i feel whatever i've been in your debt
from beginning to end
thank you
with your help
i was able to live as my own person
if only in passing
but this
is where things end no i paused to even
tell you
but i took out the needle myself
tell me whoever put you up to this
that if i am to flower into something
other than myself
i would rather rot into nothingness as i
am
oh
please
let me pass alone
the scarlet rot writhes now
worse than ever
soon
i won't be more than a mound of flesh
curse laden
untouchable
i wouldn't want such a thing to bring
you home
oh
please the scarlet draw soon
let's leave her alone chat
leave her be
we'll come back
and she'll be
she'll be gone
okay metal
no mains for us
rick does not need maidens rick is his
own maiden
while at the same time rick has all of
the maidens in the lands
all of them
well
she did
unalloyed gold needle
she dead
can we get epson chat for millicent
dab
all right
let's read the description
an intricately crafted needle of
unalloyed gold removed by millicent from
her flesh bears no trace of be fouled
blood but is faintly moist with dew
there is something i must return to
melania the dignity the sense of self
that allowed her to resist the call of
the scarlet rot
melania is not dead we are gonna go
fight melania
right now
how do i get to her from here was i
somewhere close
i go here
take her with you she's dead
i mean we don't really need to take the
hand from her do we
go talk to gallery
should we
is he there
oh
yeah let's go talk to gallery
and
[Laughter]
your point being
um
you just were there
i mean says gallery's here so i'm gonna
check
oh
this is a weird pose
my daughter
why would you take out the needle didn't
want her to die so close so very close
to becoming the fairest of all flies oh
[ __ ] you you disown us too
as your mother did
we children of the scarlet
do you detest us so utterly
[ __ ] you
blocks canvas talisman
now he's bellberry
what does that do
that guy is a piece of [ __ ]
through and through
greatly raises potency of incantations
well i don't use those
but hey
why is he holding onto his bosom
i don't know
because he's a stupid
forehead
okay do i just go out the other end of
the drainage channel
oh we bagged him
we [ __ ] bagged him
he's making clones just so they can
flower power
what an [ __ ]
using people like that
that's a good kill right chat good kill
[ __ ] that guy
[Music]
i see
is this your first playthrough yeah
no not at all it's like
so many play-throughs dude
[Music]
don't kill me let me go
let me live
[Music]
nah we aren't going to use the shield
we've got our build ready to go boys
and we are finally here
oh god
are we ready for this
are we ready for this moment
i'm scared
[Music]
i'm glad to hear that a manual
that do be pretty swaggy terrinator
this is gonna be way too easy for rick
all right we'll see
nah we'll fight melania everyone wanted
me to fight melania before malacath
you guys think she's blind
i don't think she can see
she's like instinctively fighting
against us without being able to see
which is why she like flurries around
he's blind for sure does it say that
anywhere
i'm just saying that because the rot
goes over her eyes
my flesh was dull gold
and my blood
rotted
i think we can just infer
corpse after corpse left in my wake
i will say she's [ __ ] badass
his return he is badass
that would be cool lux
heed my words
god damn it
i am melania
blade of mickeleh i know
and i have never known defeat
oh god
all right
let's get it
not a good start
oh that was just the worst dodging
you've ever seen in your life huh
she has prosthetic legs so she has never
known defeat
that is good that is [ __ ] hilarious
okay well all right let's go
let's try that again guys
oh i like that
[Music]
oh
she's holding on to that a bit longer
than you should
back it up this could be waterfowl
dab
on dim haters
there it is
this pulls it out of nowhere
yeah that was not half health but it was
close to it i should have known she
would pull that out somewhere
and just backed off
just bought a millennium miniature for
my dnd campaign that's sick actually
she is melania blade of miklos you guys
know that she's belated mcflur that
crazy
that was good dodging good [ __ ] jake
you thought
that hurt huh did that hurt
i bet
[ __ ]
was that 75 i think it was
oh i have my pots we should test that
true
it's gonna be tough
okay
i want it to be
that's fine okay
got it
[Music]
god that attack is weird
i don't think that jump attack's worth i
might stop doing that
[Music]
as i do it again
um it's possible
possible
why'd you back off
throw it
it's so fast
oh
it's so fast
oh
i'm not using bloodhound stuff
no
imagine i walk up to her and go i know
where mikala is do you think she still
fights us
good point
drew
wait
thomas
owned
oh she might just rip that out oh that's
not good
girl
girl
kill
[Music]
this isn't going well
my game froze oh
hello
my game
um
i hate it here
if i'm mid
if i'm mid attack with anything i'm dead
i can't throw the pot
mid attack
can't do it
yeah
the the one thing i don't like about and
there's i hate everything about that
attack to be honest but
it's just the fact she could just yoink
it out of nowhere and it's so fast i
just i don't like
this is something about that attack that
is just not right
imagine you use sakiro combat against
her she'd die in a second
i hope these pots are [ __ ] worth it
man
the pots aren't worth it we're somehow
alive though
i guess it's only frost pots
or i can just get really good
cause my dodging is really good right
now
look at that
i think the backstabs work though can i
get hurt
oh yeah
don't yell at me vip
no i [ __ ] had no stamina
well when you put an exclamation point
on the end of it then i think you're
yelling at me
that's usually what that means
it's just basic grammar
this is not going well okay
let's step back
it was nice from here
that attack is one of the hardest in the
game for me i don't know why it's just
weird
wow all right she's just throwing that
[ __ ] out everywhere
just yoinking it around
guys stop dude i swear to god i swear
bro let me do this let me learn the
dodges stop back seeding
if you all backseat too much i'm gonna
get [ __ ] furious bro
it'll be a fury of rage and you won't
like it
shut the [ __ ] up let me play the game
thank you
[Music]
and it staggers you
a he'll save me there
i'm gonna yoink that out
knew it
not the best that but
something
oh
it's so hard because she goes around you
and then the camera follows her and then
you roll the direction you don't want to
go
maybe i should turn off the camera
when she does that
dude that that [ __ ] attack right
there is i don't know what it is about
it i hate it
someone time out ac for the day he's
just being an [ __ ]
i'll do it i don't like you dude you're
[ __ ] douche every time i see you in
chat you're just being a dick
probably jokingly but shut up
put on some background music i won't get
copyrighted
[Music]
so bad
i like the music in this fight
[Music]
she does so much damage dude
what was that attack
blade
let's start with negative hp
use rivers of blood
no
i have to let her attack first
thought i was out of range
[Music]
level 125
[Music]
why did my person not attack again it
was weird
i had stamina
[Music]
i went for something crazy there bro i
just didn't expect you to do it that
early
[ __ ]
ah
come on backseat one more time i'm just
gonna [ __ ] time you out the rest of
the day dude
you're not helping
so
yeah that was like perfect
almost
off
the aggro
this feeler doing it
yes
[Music]
that was not
okay that didn't really help turning it
off
[Music]
suck jake don't mean to catch you at a
bad time but love you glad to catch you
street oh
oh no
thank you i appreciate the ten dollars
but the timing
oh god
that hurt
i immediately looked away i don't want
to blame you for that but damn
thank you dude i really appreciate the
ten dollars i really do
oh the pain that hurt
it's okay we weren't gonna get it on
that one anyway i don't think
thank you very much no you're good i
really appreciate it
you're good that's that was [ __ ]
funny
we weren't gonna get it on that one it's
okay
we haven't been stage two yet
[Music]
all right
we're going off millennium
really only get one hit in
hit roll man
[Music]
would she do it now no
the fact she can make up all that ground
when she's that far away in a
millisecond is quite insane
you could definitely do it now yup
any night
hmm
oh my god she's just so aggro right now
i need to back off a little bit further
that's okay we got away with it
[Music]
dude the fact i wasn't far enough away
there bro god
dude i oh my god why are people so
[ __ ] annoying
you're using too many flasks you can't
win this with that weapon bro just
saying you can't
shut the [ __ ] up you [ __ ]
i can do whatever i want and i will do
it like this got up
[ __ ] loser
that
go play pvp and use rivers of blood and
you think you're good at the game
imagine
secondary weapon moonvale probably
[ __ ] nude
blade
hmm
i was kidding you can use whatever
weapon you want in pvp they should
balance it
[Music]
she she held that [ __ ]
dude she held it
that was that
no we can definitely do it like this i
just can't mess up
can't mess up
that was really bad
yeah yep i deserve that blade
got me every hit there
oh
do you guys think the game takes a bit
of a insane
spike in difficulty
like a little bit too
heavy of a spike
it's like we really haven't struggled at
all
that much with any boss we tried five
times on moog and this seems [ __ ]
crazy hard
level 125
nice
he's backing off that's a good sign
yes
[Music]
backing off a lot
do you see her hold that
he does it fast and sometimes slow
[Music]
he just did it fast
right there
in that time it was slower 100
that is cheeky
let me
[Music]
leave be alone you only need to get the
fight right once it will happen you got
this thank you calvin and i agree
we do got this
we got this
come on
come on calm down millennia
we haven't used mimic yet either i'm
kind of waiting for stage two to use it
but
see
[Music]
my dodging's getting a lot better
as i say that
thank you calvin
very nice of you
and uh and she delays it right there and
it gets me because i roll too early
as she spams her [ __ ] attacks at me
dude
i do think this fight's really cool but
there's a lot of dumb [ __ ] with this
fight bro there really [ __ ] is
hide
we haven't struggled on any boss with
this build up to this point
mmm
fine let's get it stop bitching and get
better that's the answer let's go [ __ ]
you i'm gonna win
nice pot buddy
that's what i like to see right there
yep
i'm gonna run away
let my boy get hit by that yep yep yep
and alder held this back
why was my salmon solo i think i ran
over
the fact she gets health back from my
mimic is kind of annoying
nice combo
oh
didn't even get hit
oh that [ __ ]
kick
keeping my distance because i just feel
it enter
the mimic is not plus ten it's plus
three four
it's probably an issue
come on
soon
how can she catch me as i'm full
sprinting away from her
we'll take a little look
dodges are getting better
we are learning
[Music]
nice [ __ ]
you're gonna do it soon
i know you
got the little delay i don't like it
because she's hot i mean blind oh god
that wasn't very good but we'll take it
feels new to me
our best damn it
doing so good
and waterfowl
[Music]
i thought i could reach her
hmm
dude
it's doing so well
and then
gone she gets so much health back
hitting it i man dude
i don't want a [ __ ] about this fight
but
bro there is something wrong about this
fight it's hard for dumb reasons like i
did so good there it it's like a 10
minute fight and i can't even get to
stage two
hitting her consistently
dodging consistently and then just
[ __ ] four waterfowls in the first
stage
i have never known her to have that
delay there and i'm just gonna keep
complaining about it because i just
don't recognize it at all
feels new
but maybe i'm wrong
i feel like i love this fight and i also
hate it
his twice as much health and as madeira
and she can heal
that's great
you're a bastard
nope
nice
[ __ ]
i'm gonna gas through it
no way
i shouldn't have gasped
like every hit just like she staggered
me on her first little thing there and
it just i couldn't move anymore
god
dang it
hey i could i'm playing perfectly until
she just gets me once
damn it
that was stupid
heal come on come on
[Music]
resetting my brain
not a good follow-up though this is bad
wow
i don't know what it is about that
attack this can't [ __ ]
read it
yeah she is demoralizing i that's a
perfect way to describe her
just demoralizing
you're gonna do it aren't you
i'm gonna do it soon
did this dodge too early on this third
one there i don't know
[Music]
didn't have stamina i think
that was good
we'll take that
[Music]
you're gonna water fowl though aren't
you
yep she's not like she's in that little
mode
bruh that is just [ __ ] insane
if she gets you with one of those you're
staggered and it's over you are getting
hit by everything
there you go
perfect
good [ __ ]
almost panic roll there
[Music]
it's a weird combo from her
[Music]
i am
really
yeah i just got to do the rick roll if i
do the rick roll then we'll be good
[Music]
[Music]
i'm just gonna hit
that's fine
[Music]
okay
i'll take that
imagine
uh imagine
please [ __ ] off
i just do it here
that's
fringe
[Music]
dude like [ __ ]
like she just gets more hits the lower
her health is
[Music]
oh
i thought she was just backing up there
this one
[Music]
knew it
pretty good
not good not good at all
not dang it
nope
you're not dead
excuse me
all right sure i
yeah all right i'll just take another
hit there for
whatever reason
jesus
welcome back from work flanders
time to [ __ ] cry now
wait
100 more subs than when the shindig
started really oh we have gotten a lot
of subs
damn thank you
thank you guys
all right time to cry
prepare to cry
[Music]
the scarlet blue flowers once more
yeah we don't have it on this run we're
gonna get there though we're getting a
lot better as we go along
oh god
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
the only word i have for this
um
i [ __ ] up
i completely forgot how to dodge the
beginning part
uh i just run
now i remember
wow
uh
yup
hey at least we got there this time
right
now we know
totally forgot
now i remember
[Music]
i forgot the rick roll you know
nice
let me turn on a light
[Music]
much better
um
[Music]
if i wait a little bit longer and get
her twice there
that's not good
oh she just pulled that [ __ ] out of
nowhere dude and just
when you're too close you die that's how
that works
never gonna goop
level 125.
if you up
you can use bloodhound step just because
you said that i'm gonna die and it's
your fault i'm just gonna stand here and
die
got up
that's your fault for saying something
so hideous
i am soldier of god
my name is rick
and i'll beat her like this
yeah no [ __ ]
it's quick step on steroids who cares
[Music]
yeah three hits never works
never works
[Music]
didn't i just say to just not do three
hits my game froze oh we're freezing
we're dying
so
rick
has never known defeat
ever
[Music]
i refuse to lose and i refuse to use
blood bloodhound step [ __ ] rivers of
blood
i refuse
yeah sorry to lash out on you on that
but people have been giving back seating
like a bunch of
stop backseating
make memes
make memes joke around discuss amongst
yourselves but do not tell me to change
what i'm doing thank you
[Music]
all right
good start
[Music]
i just want to go again this is awful
this couldn't be a worse start she's
aggroed oh
oh
all right
oh just kill me
this came out so hot
[Music]
it jumped over
yeah just restart that one that was
terrible
[Music]
taking a break is an option no that's
what a [ __ ] does i'm gonna sit here
sweating and complaining my ass off like
a true gamer
until i get it
take a break
got your
i butthole she was facing the other way
was her um
her sword electric there
did you see that
i think it was reflecting in the water
actually
nice
[Music]
dude
she keeps moving right out of the way
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
you broke your chair
she's gonna do it
really soon
thought it was sprinting
nope i'm gonna get caught in some
[ __ ]
i feel it
interesting putt back
there you go
i went for the jump attack i saw someone
say it
i'm an idiot
excuses
more excuses
it's unfortunate
okay
[Music]
ah just all ends just like that
i don't know what noise just came out of
my mouth but
wow okay that's the sound that happened
[Music]
oo woo
just the just the [ __ ] fact she could
pull that out of where
while i'm hitting her
[ __ ]
remember two months ago when i did a
stream that we titled five hours of
dying nabalenia
[Music]
getting uh similar vibes
could do it
use that to heal
we can attack
you know follow that up with waterfowl
i thought i was far enough away
that's that's the reason this fight
sucks i'll say it the reason this fight
sucks is because the only thing i'm
constantly thinking about is when she's
gonna use the waterfowl if that is a
part of your fight
that's not good design i'm sorry this is
bad [ __ ] design
her design is great
that one attack is [ __ ] it's such
dog [ __ ] it makes the fight bad
everything else about the fight is great
just that one attack
is such utter dog [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
go
no
[Music]
yeah let me solo her
goes in every 20 minutes to hit her
i'd rather not do that
[Music]
you should use that attack again melania
should do that again
it's crazy
ah she took my advice
thought i was far enough away
surprise that hit
cool dude
it would be easy without her waterfowl
dance i mean
they can have the waterfowl but i just i
don't think it's that attack is balanced
it just doesn't feel right it if you're
too close
and by the way it's just your first
flurry
that is undodgeable if you're too close
the other two are dodgeable at all times
that's fine
just the fact that you can't dodge
something
based
on how close you are
it's [ __ ]
like i think it would be balanced if she
took longer to load up that first flurry
[Music]
like a second longer
wouldn't it wouldn't even be that much
but
it is what it is
really [ __ ] over melee
it's just the fact that it's the only
attack i'm thinking of
that shouldn't happen in your fight this
shouldn't
but there it is
i i went for a heavy attack
when
you know she's down and then she can
just fly up into the sky and kill you
instantly
i mean you can knock her out of the
animation you have to use [ __ ] frost
pots that i don't think is
it every that that's the thing about
these souls games man you should be if
you can be good enough to dodge then
that should be enough
but the fact that you can't dodge
or first flurry if you're too close
is ridiculous
[Music]
imo
i mean look at all that space i had to
get to barely get off the heel
that's not even waterfowl
it was across the map across the
arena look all i'm thinking about is
when is she gonna do it
plus i have to fade her out of it just
so i'm not too close to not instantly
die
all right
ever doing a jump attack there
[Music]
again don't think sister freda's
[ __ ]
i do think melania's [ __ ]
every single one of the sister frida's
attacks are dodgeable
not the case with millennia
i keep timing this right can i stun
locker
maybe
unless she does that
you can dodge at close range
consistently that's just not true that's
not true at all
the first flurry you can't dodge if
you're too close
i don't know why people say that
it's not true unless you have like
bloodhound stuff
this base mechanics you can face base
roll
[Music]
mine
like i was doing so well
so well
and then there it is
and it's over
like are there really people out there
who don't think that's [ __ ]
[Music]
like i die five times to moog and i'm
gonna die dozens of times to a like
similar area boss
like similar in-game boss
[Music]
oh like i said can't dodge the first
flurry
you can dodge the other two
yeah if you have the armor and stuff you
can take it
you have insane poise
[Music]
and a shield
really
so
i'm not saying i can't it's literally
been tested it's known that you can't
dodge if you're too close without using
some type of exploit on the first
flurry
someone banned amazing you're such a
[ __ ]
you just been bitching shut the [ __ ] up
i've been talking [ __ ] the whole time
thank you
he's just been saying you can't do it
for like an hour
[ __ ] loser
why am i not
[Music]
oh that's that's waterfowl
i couldn't even tell if it was waterfowl
or not
use a pot when she jumps up like
oh holy [ __ ]
[Music]
and yeah the fight's hard enough and
then you have like people in your chat
[ __ ] telling you how to do something
like shut the [ __ ] up
do it my way that i did in my
playthrough like shut up what a loser
mentality
let me do it my way
like how the game was designed for me to
do
[Music]
how many bosses you have left we have
melania malacath i mean we have a lot of
like little bosses to do but we'll do
that
just running through the end of the game
okay ban that guy who just added me the
[ __ ] wrong with you weirdo
[Music]
[Music]
i'm gonna do this now
[Music]
oh that's
yep
all right coming
nice just
nice
you're kidding
i feel like she just did it
oh she just whips it out whenever she
wants just with the biggest
ugh
taking greed swings isn't helping you
say one more dumbass thing like that
austin like you have been for the past
hour
and you're banned i'm over it you've
been a dick all day shut up
what
i didn't have stamina
i'm not salty for yelling at a dude
who's being a dick in my chat shut the
[ __ ] up
oh
[Music]
so
me up
oh
didn't like that attempt anyway
we are making progress every time i mean
we might have like one just bad try but
we're making progress my computer's
working but
[Music]
need to get up
good
call probably do it
i'm scared
it should be enough for her to go
come on
thank you
i ran
quite literally immediately how did i
not get far enough away
how is that possible
how did i not get far enough away
i baited her out ran away straight back
and she still caught me
oh i hope you banned austin that guy can
go [ __ ]
[ __ ] himself jesus
i'm fine
this chat sucks right now like five
percent of the chat sucks everyone else
is great
holy [ __ ] leave your suggestions at the
door it is unwelcome as i've said for
the last hour and a half
let me bang my head against the wall
until i get this
like the whole point is to do this with
this build
without any exploits
soldier of god rick that's the that's
the
role play we're doing here
pretty obvious with this shitty armor
is that the second time of staggered
she's got a waterfall
that's exactly what's gonna happen
pascal we're just gonna have an amazing
run and we'll get it
how these games work
sometimes the camera kind of [ __ ] me up
there
and it like pulls me in when i thought i
was dodging away
uh they put all the patch notes on
twitter
i'd go look there it was a lot of bug
fixes
third stagger in stage one
that was way too [ __ ] risky i don't
know why i did that
lady let me leave thank you
no i wasn't
i i was holding it
do you guys sometimes have stamina and
you're holding down sprint and your
character just does not go
sometimes
maybe that's just me but i know i had
stamina i know i'm holding down sprint
and my character is just walking
yeah we've been to stage two a couple
times or a few times
maybe two or three i don't remember
i think two or three
yeah that's really annoying
especially when i have to run
before i die
guys it input delay
probably
[Music]
[Music]
just
out of nowhere over and over again
no [ __ ] re hi hello get it
just
whips it out
whenever she feels like it
just whoop
god i am streaming until i get this dude
i'm doing it i'm streaming until i beat
this
beautiful
[Music]
so
[Music]
i don't know if her health is down
enough to do it
now it is
did not think that would hit me
oh okay twice
all right yep
i'm just gonna spam all my attacks until
i get you
i'm just gonna spam
[ __ ] l and the entire time all i'm
thinking is bait out waterfowl
warren should have been upgradable
through
dude my dodging's getting so good it's
just that one [ __ ] attack
come on just do it
what's up new journey
what am i looking for
oh
wow
really good
stay there
thank you
not exactly what i wanted
okay that was weird
weird attack
hmm
that would have been sad
no
back off stop
this is not doing what i want i'm trying
to beat the waterfowl and she just won't
do it
cool
i don't know how you see
those last five minutes and not think
this fights [ __ ]
of me dodging literally [ __ ]
everything
perfectly and finally just being like
you know what i'm gonna go in and and
get a hit in because she just doesn't
want to do the waterfowl
and then i get one hit in
and then she just [ __ ] does it it's
such [ __ ]
anyone who doesn't like doesn't think
that's [ __ ] is just [ __ ] wrong
sorry
[Music]
ah
oops
that was my fault completely i just
didn't dodge in time
no dude
it's been proven i've i'm not even gonna
talk about it i've said it so many times
you cannot dodge the first phase the
first little flurry of the waterfowl you
[ __ ] can't anyone who's saying you
can you're using bloodhound step or some
other [ __ ] i'm talking just dodging
just rolling
like you should be able to
you can do the other two but not the
first one
it's been proven tested it is impossible
if you're too [ __ ] close
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nice delay
okay
oh that is just paint
bro just as soon as she gets low on
health she just starts going crazy
can't even hit her anymore
so
nick
got stuck there's something in the
flowers right there that gets me stuck
every time i run over it
i got greedy i guess
i don't even know
that's so sad
i'm getting burnt out by chat you guys
are just so [ __ ] stupid like you're
just saying [ __ ]
it's like you can dodge it
what is the percentage
like nothing
close to zero
[Music]
i knew it too
that's impressive
you pin your comment metal
no
oh no
[Music]
i got stuck on her toes
i think i can
hold on
i think that stays at the top now right
that's pretty cool
thank you donnie
ban gilgamesh i'm over him
shut the [ __ ] up
every time i see you in chat you're
literally still talking like giving
suggestions it's insane
like how many times can i say don't give
me suggestions and you still do it like
are you brain dead
whatever the [ __ ] his name is
he's been here the whole time
got it that point's just your [ __ ]
fault
say it out loud to the monitor i won't
be able to hear you but at least you'll
be able to get your dumb ass comment out
of the way without it entering my chat
room
then you wouldn't have got banned
[Music]
so
no
sometimes she just steps way further
than she normally does and just gets you
on that attack
you know you're gonna pull it out of
your ass girl
that's just my fault it's not a good run
[Music]
god dude sometimes she gets in these
modes of where like she just goes into
those perfect
counters to what you're doing
and i just
i'm either trying to bait her out or she
just does the perfect counter and i just
die
thanks ghost
glad you like him man
that's a great way to put that samuel
pin that
[Music]
so
[Music]
yeah animation's too slow and i'm stuck
in a corner with her health low enough
to do the waterfowl this is not good
we got really lucky
i think
[Music]
i tried i sometimes i get stuck on her
toe and it actually blocks me from
moving into a roll
don't look so glum cause
yeah dude i did not think we'd struggle
this much
i i feel like i'm dodging really well
it's just
it's just waterfowl
crazy as she goes left there i can dodge
that but since she went right
[Music]
i was thinking of playing dark souls 2
next
god i thought she went up in the air for
waterfowl i'm not even not even [ __ ]
around with that
oh no i'm at an angle
we'll take that that's good that's good
[ __ ]
yeah back up [ __ ]
i can do it
you just can't be greedy at all
just if there's a sliver of a chance she
can use waterfowl
just a just a tiny little [ __ ] sliver
man
[Music]
wow everything's gonna hit there huh
cool
[Music]
[Music]
turn into mickey mouse for a second
i don't think i've played dark souls 2
enough to even have an opinion on it i
played through it i don't even think i
finished it
i really don't think so
i definitely haven't played the dlc
which i heard is the best part
nice let's get the delay on that one and
then i almost die
or get hit
it's already swinging damn
i think i ran out of stamina right there
i don't know why my character just
stopped running
i
am just the same thing over and over
again
[Music]
i love sakura skiro's awesome
i think i i think sekiro has the best
combat in any of these games
[Music]
yeah i don't think dark souls 2 is a bad
game it's just a bad souls game exactly
i agree
maybe my expectations were too high for
it
because my order of playing the games
were not normal
i played dark souls 3 first
when it came out
and then i played dark souls 1 really
liked it and then i played dark souls 2
and i was like what the [ __ ] is this
it was just really different so maybe
that's what i didn't like about it
i'd want to play it again though for
sure
just to give it a test if we hate it we
hate it
oh she is really aggressive
that was pretty risky
gotta stop jump attacking there doesn't
work
what
then then my role went through
nice fade
she was to my right and then behind and
then right on top of me
okay
thing is we beat her we roll through the
rest of the game won't even be close
no i don't think they'll make dark souls
4. i think dark souls is over
dark souls 3 concluded the dark souls
series so perfectly it would be kind of
a crime to have dark souls 4.
not that i wouldn't like one
it's not necessary
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i think bloodborne 2 is their next
logical step
besides dlc
for this game
although that game could stay standalone
just really aggressive this run
you mean waterfowl
there you go
[Music]
get it
nope and she's gone
that's bad
see right there that's where i think
she's blind
this is doing it
she gets in this
mode right before a waterfowl
potentially
it's like she's baiting me
she probably is
[Music]
came out like three years ago it does
not need to be remastered yet
just dying the same way over and over
again
oh on new gen
maybe
[Music]
really bad start dude
what
okay i'll take that
the thing is guys we're doing plenty of
damage
we're just dying to one attack at this
point
i mean we are doing plenty of damage
for this fight
it's quite literally one attack i'm
dying to over and over again
i'm doing a pretty decent job not right
there but pretty decent job of dodging
everything else
so
oh [ __ ]
dude
just get good it's true
[Music]
i just don't understand her movement
when she's doing the waterfowl she's all
over you
and then i'll dodge in the same way
and i just won't get hit
and then sometimes i'll just get
annihilated
quite a lock if you think about it
nice delay [ __ ] [ __ ]
absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous
yeah we can use a summon i just want to
use it in phase two we can't even get to
phase two now
hey i think even my mom would call the
melania a [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
that was me
let me get out of here
oh how do you
watch that second one
oh i'm dead
yeah yeah
pro streamer
how do you dodge that you don't
when you're too close like i was
this entire fight is baiting out one
attack it's
terrible
[Music]
come on
dude
i got caught
ah damn it
it's so frustrating
okay
why i'm trading hits with you i couldn't
be dumber against you
wow that's a combo
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what
just did a [ __ ] 360. okay
[Music]
[ __ ] you
it's kind of weird
what just happened
like how did that happen
she got up and just kept going
i even hit her again
what was that
i thought that was waterfowl and i was
gonna poop my pants
oh now she's doing it
blind dodgy
look at that
my man rick
so
[Music]
that's terrifying
my game is dying
other rick is dead
so other rick pretty much just healed
her that's what just happened
[Music]
[Music]
robbed
she just did so
did it so much faster than usual on that
when she flies up in the air
he has different like timings for stuff
i feel like you know
he waterfowled rick into death and got
all her health back i think that was the
big problem there
unfortunately
okay back off
his health is pretty low nice
that's fine
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna back off because that's
really good
all right okay
[Music]
[Music]
odds she busts it out
[Music]
there it is and i have to get lucky
we didn't
like i i quite literally couldn't have
played better
until she does that right in that moment
i
i could not have done better
and then it it just ends right there
[ __ ]
i was just super unlucky
[Music]
that attack is
crazy
hard to dodge it's really strange
[Music]
nice my game just completely freezes
sometimes
he wants to waterfowl
and just spam all the other [ __ ] we
have as well
yep doing full spam mode instead of just
doing the waterfowl
as soon as i dude
i mean it's just such [ __ ]
it's such [ __ ]
the one [ __ ] moment
just can't take the risk i'm i'm done
moving in i like half debate it out i
have to or we die
it's the only way we're dying at this
point
[Music]
sit low enough i don't know
and [ __ ]
this fight shall be won by courage and
in memory of the fallen soldiers of god
rick who came before
you god damn right thank you appreciate
that
i'm not gonna risk it here
thank you for the six dollars and ninety
cents thank you
god damn right
[Music]
sorry if i'm not talking to you guys
very much i am focused as hell
well
didn't think after her doing a
combo twice in a row that she'd just
pull out of grab cool
we're fine
but just like that
like what are
what the [ __ ] odds
not going for it
i was gonna go for another one but
it's a bit risky
um
[Music]
nice
come on other rick
[Music]
what did i get hit by
other rick please
[Music]
he's looking at me
oh he's dead
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh we're getting so close
just
i just need rick not to die so fast
i just need him to not die in half a
second
i think we need to do i think we really
need to upgrade him
because i mean he he just gets
annihilated
over
damn bro
where are four and five
is it gravestone i'm gonna go back
he just dies in half a second middle
the plan has been to use him stage two
but it doesn't really help when he dies
in
half a second
i see
so it's ghost glove wart
ball bearing four and five
and do i have them now so i can turn
them in
i can get one twos threes i need a four
and a five and i can pretty much do the
rest
she really is breaking my mental state
vapor i am exhausted
no i won't kill him in one go
where where can i get four and five
someone said altus where in altus
catacombs and all this has them
underground
i mean technically i'm taking a break
right now
uh
which which catacombs
knock stella
knock stella
so here
minor urgery catacombs
is that like here
yeah
where's the bell bearing is that
underground you said
you guys are saying a lot of different
thing i need a four and a five i have
the rest i just need a four and a five
uh ghost
love wart
i think my game crashed
uh oh
i think it legitimately crashed
well
up there it is
it died
i don't know if that's a sign
but
going back in
you got mowed
[Music]
is a bell bearing 3 where i can get a 4
and a 5.
bilbari no for um sorry for ghost glove
wart
i'm just gonna look it up i'm getting a
bunch of different
uh
answers here
it was ghost right it was a glove work
or
sure
um
hey knock stella
up the stairs
and then is that it
okay
dude i get so confused where [ __ ] is
the brain's tripping right now where the
hell am i
there we go
all the way over there
nope i not for this one i want to do
this on my own with this build
rascal
it could be something fun we do in the
future though for sure
this isn't it
there's a somber 7 if you're ever
curious
interesting
could be this in the corner
bum
god i'm so tired that is a lot of brain
power i don't know why i went over here
there's a lot of brain power to fight
melania
we are having fun
i'm having fun
i just want to [ __ ] do it dude
and godskin novels aren't that bad
after a certain amount
so
four or five okay so we need some rooney
boys
okay
i lost all my [ __ ] [ __ ] to her
okay
[Music]
oh i see
i see
oh it's so expensive
i know what to do
this is just the first one
it's on my mind honestly
wait that's halo tree
call me jake wick
she's a spirit tuner i don't know what
you want to do let's do dragon word
i don't like rune farming
i think it's lame
you can do it if you want though
oh yeah yeah i almost bought them again
i see
house
think that's good enough
oh i should fully upgrade
it's expensive dawg uh where's another
one that we've knocked down
we knocked down the one over here
here wait
is that over here
no i won't think less of you
[Music]
i just don't want to do it myself
i don't like it
he mowed your brain dude
she's tough bro
and we've been close
i don't want to get out of the flow if i
get out of the flow
then that'll suck
did i already use one here
i guess so
i don't know if i knocked this one down
i just i definitely think we can do it
if we have a fully upgraded mimic
dammit
oh
these mausoleums are [ __ ] sick
i remember they got me so excited when
the trailer for the game came out like
last year
uh i guess it doesn't matter
yeah i might try and use them in the
first place in the first phase for a bit
see how well it goes and then get him in
this stage too i might not want to do
that actually because stage two is just
like
all right he's fully upgraded stage two
is just
[ __ ] uh
he's gonna walk
directly into the uh
the [ __ ] scarlet rot and just die
i'm gonna try it let's see how it goes
yeah she's taking a break right now too
true
let's give it a shot
nice throw rick
as he gets that hit though
[Music]
very nice rick
waterfowl
i just don't want to die to it
or we can just beat the [ __ ] out of her
we will take a look there
she hasn't staggered again
as i say that
[Music]
well that was a lot [ __ ] easier
wasn't it chat
rick stay out of it oh god
[Music]
miss rick
and he's done
wow
so she goes cross map for that huh
i i i
i don't know how you watch this stream
and don't think this fights [ __ ] i
just don't
yeah we're gonna get it soon now but i
mean what
i i don't know how you watch the stream
and think this fight's fair
fight's absolutely ridiculous
[Music]
laughs
nice
hahaha
keep going rick
oh almost died
[Music]
stop healing lady
okay
rick come on man oh god
no shot rick flips through this man
[Music]
well
it's all down to me
[Music]
why not
[Music]
so
[Music]
that's waterfowl
really
i feel like she just did this right
not like this
[Music]
please
yes
the true lord
dear mickeleh
oh
dearest nicholas
[Laughter]
i'm sorry
i finally met
my man
rick was your match
all rick
dab on them haters
as we do
we did it
we [ __ ] did it
i can't believe it somewhat
first try right guys
return the needle
guys
i'm gonna go get some food i'm starving
that's definitely the longest stream
we've done on youtube
and i didn't think uh that would take
that long
however
we did it
we actually [ __ ] did it dude
i feel good about it
but i am exhausted
we did fight placidu sax we did do that
we did that five hours ago so
anyway
we did it
rick
is probably the best build
in all of elden
ring he is the soldier of god himself
and his name is rick
now i don't want to do needle yet we're
going to do that we're going to have
chat choose the ending we want when we
have that option at the end
so yeah
i am getting out of here and i am
starving
thank you very much for all the support
today you guys were
insane a lot of people here really
appreciate it
we had to yell at some you but you know
or we had to yell at some you we had to
yell at some of you
uh for being
[ __ ]
but uh
hey it is what it is
so i appreciate all the support thank
you for being here thanks for all the
subs got a lot of subs today i don't
know why but we did
um
and we'll be back tomorrow probably okay
okay
so you all have a great rest of your day
have a great night
go get some food
and i'll see you all again soon
peace and love
take care
bye dudes thanks